Now, getting sounds into grits was a bit of an interesting process. You see we
really didn't have funds to actually get a sound designer to make anything for
us. So we had to act like a scrappy little start up. This actually started at
the beginning. Where do we get our sounds? Well, thanks to the indie gaming
boom of 2009, there's actually tons and tons of resources out there for
independent game developers to go get sounds for free. So we employed that
strategy. Now when you do this, be very clear of what you're actually getting.
Most sounds on the Internet actually follow with some sort of weird licensing
restriction, either Creative Commons or attribution or something along those
lines. So when you grab your sound, make sure you understand how you have to
credit it. Usually it comes with something. The second thing you have to worry
about is when you grab a lot of sounds from the internet that were made from
different designers on different sound boards, they probably aren't very
unified, which means they're not going to sound cohesive inside of your game.
For this, you actually need to take your sounds through a post-processing tool.
Personal favorite of mine is one called Goldwave, I've been using it probably
since about 1998, it's free and easy to grab on Windows. Inside of these tools,
you basically want to cut your sounds, trim your sounds and make it sound as
though everything is in the same environment. Case in point, there's a lot of
little gotchas out there when you're trying to get good content into a game.
And sounds are really tricky to do. So do your due diligence, post process your
sounds, make awesome. [SOUND]